[BEEPING]
SPEAKER: When building
apps, developers
rely on various cloud services
including storage, messaging,
data analytics, and
mobile development.
As developers expand their
use, seamless integration
between these services
can be a real challenge.
Google Cloud Functions is
a server list execution
environment for building and
connecting cloud services.
With Cloud Functions, you
write simple, single-purpose
functions that are attached to
events emitted from your cloud
infrastructure and services.
Your Cloud Function is triggered
when an event being watched
is fired.
Cloud events are
things that happen
in your cloud environment.
These might be things like
changes to data in a database,
files added to a storage
system, or a new virtual machine
instance being created.
Events occur whether or not
you choose to respond to them.
You create a response to
an event with a trigger.
A trigger is a
declaration that you
are interested in a certain
event or set of events.
Finding a function to a trigger
allows you to capture and act
on events.
For more information on creating
triggers and associating them
with your functions, see events
and triggers linked below.
Your code executes in a
fully managed environment.
There is no need to
provision any infrastructure
or worry about
managing any servers.
This hands-on lab shows you
how to create, deploy, and test
a Cloud Function using
Google Cloud Console.
So what you'll do in this lab is
create a Google Cloud Function,
deploy and test the
function, view the logs.
By the end, you will have
deployed, tested, and viewed
the logs of your application.
Next up on our quest is Google
Cloud Pub/Sub Qwik Start
Console.